sometimes when you're doing a large
multi-part proof like this it's easy to
lose your bearings we're trying to prove
the divergence theorem when we started
off just rewriting the flux across the
surface and rewriting the the the triple
integral of the divergence and we said
well if we can prove that each of these
components are equal to each other we
will have our proof done and what i said
is is that we're going to use the fact
this is a type 1 region to prove this
part the fact that it's a type 2 region
to prove this part and the fact that
it's a type 3 region to prove this part
in particular i'm going to show the fact
that if it is a type 1 region we can
prove this and you can use the exact
same argument to prove the other two in
which case the divergence theorem would
be correct so we're focused on this part
right here and in particular we're
focused on evaluating the surface
integral and to evaluate that surface
integral we broke up the entire surface
into three surfaces that upper bound on
z the lower bound on z and kind of the
side of if you imagine this some type of
a funky cylinder these don't have to be
flats flat tops and bottoms and for a
type 1 region you don't even have to
have this side surface this is only for
the case where the two surfaces don't
touch each other within this domain
right over here so we broke it up into
three surfaces but we said look the
normal vector along the side right over
here is never going to have is never
going to have a k component and so when
you take the drop dot product with the k
unit vector this is just going to cross
out so our surface integral simplified
to the surface integral over s2 and the
surface integral of s1 and in the last
video we evaluated the surface integral
of s2 or at least we turned it into a
double integral over the domain now
going to do the same exact thing with s1
so let's just remind ourselves what we
are concerned with we want to re-express
s1
we want to re-express s1 and s1 and this
integral the surface integral we i
should say we want to re-express the
surface integral over s1 it was r of x y
and z up here we just wrote r but this
is making it explicit that r is a
function of x y and z
times
k
dot n
d s and the way we evaluate any surface
integral is we want to make sure that we
or we want to have a parameterization
for our actual surface so let's
introduce a parameterization for a
surface let's say that s1
s1 and i'll use i the letter o is kind
of a weird one to use looks like a zero
and we're already using for a normal
vector let's use the let's use e so the
parameterization of our surface could be
x times i plus y times j
plus and it's a type 2 region our
surface is a function of x and y plus
f1
which is a function of xy times k we see
f1 right over here that's our lower
bound that's our lower bound on our
region
and then this is 4
for all of the xy pairs that are a
member
a member of our domain in question so we
have our parameterization and now we can
think about now we can think about how
we can write this right over here the
nds and so n
times ds we've done this multiple
multiple multiple times which is
actually the same thing as ds which is
the same thing as ds we've done this
multiple times this is equal to the
cross product of the parameterization in
one direction with respect to one
parameter and then that cross with
respect to the other parameter and then
that times d a but we want to make sure
we get the order right so i'm going to
claim that this is going to be the
partial of our parameterization
with respect to y crossed with the
partial of our parameterization with
respect to x and then we have times d a
but we need to make sure this has the
right orientation because for this
bottom surface remember we need to be
pointed we need to be pointed straight
down outward from the region so if we're
going in the y direction the partial
with respect to y is like that the
partial with respect to x is like that
and if you use the right hand rule your
thumb will point downward like that i
could draw my right hand my index finger
could go like that my middle finger
would bend like this i don't really care
what my other two fingers do and then my
thumb would go downwards so this is the
right ordering which is the which is a
different ordering or it's the opposite
ordering as we did last time we'll see
we'll just get a negative value but
let's just work it through
just to be a little bit more convincing
so this business right over here is
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to let's write
our i
j
and k
unit vectors
it's going to be all of that times d a
so the partial of e with respect to y
partial of e with respect to y 0
0 1 partial of f 1 partial of f f1 with
respect to y
partial with respect to x is going to be
0 partial of f1 with respect to x and
then when you evaluate this whole thing
so let me draw a little dotted line here
this is going to be equal to
some business times i minus some other
business times j and on our k component
you're going to have 0 times 0 minus 1
times k
so minus k and then all of that
all of that times d a and now the reason
why i didn't take even worry about what
these things are going to be is i'm
going to take the dot product with k
so this whole thing all of this business
right over here i can now express in the
x y domain i can now write is going to
be equal to
the double integral and let me do it in
that same purple color because that was
the original color for that surface
integral it's going to be the double
integral over the domain our parameters
domain the in the in the x y plane
of r
of
x
let me write this a little bit cleaner
r of x
y
instead of z i'm going to write z over
that surface is f 1 of x and y so that
we have everything in terms of our
parameters
times all of this business k dotted this
well what is k dotted this well the dot
product of k and negative k is negative
1 so we're just going to be with left
with negative d a so we'll put the d a
out front here and we are left with
and we have a negative d a right over
here so we have now expressed we have
now expressed
this surface integral this surface
integral as the sum of two double
integrals as the sum of
as the sum of and let me find it the sum
of this
the sum of that and that
right over there and actually let me
just let me just rewrite it just so that
we can make everything clear so this
surface integral
so let me write it right over here the
surface integral over our entire surface
of r times k
dot n
d s
is equal to
the double integral and i'll do this in
a new color
is equal to the double integral in the
in the domain d
of
of this thing minus this thing d a
so i'll write r
of x
y
and f 2 of x
and that's that minus this
minus
r of x
y
and f2
of x sorry f1 be careful here f1
of x
y that's this thing right over here all
of that
all of that
all of that times d a
now we just showed this is equal to this
all we have to show now
is that this is also equal to that same
expression and we will have proven this
for the type 1 case and we can use the
exact same argument for the type 2 and
type 3 cases and feel good that the
divergence theorem is about to be proven
for a simple solid region